hello there welcome to this video it's
very rainy day today it is raining but
one thing I do like about the rain is
that you get big puddles and cars just
drive through them just unleashing tidal
waves on pedestrians I happen to be
walking by looks awesome yeah I think
that would look really cool in slow-mo
luckily sign have provided us the
perfect car for the job the FRS all
right so here's the car it looks so warm
and dry in there oh yeah this is Scion
racing driver Kendra she can go see this
is Dan Gritti all right can't do it how
do you feel about Justin I'll aim that's
what the time as long as I'm dry it's
all good all right it's good all right
for you then we'll be over there by the
puddle car it's gonna get wet
all right so here's the splash you ready
no all right no not let's do it
well that was successful safe you call
successful freezing title wedding yeah
sure our backs
oh thanks for Scion for lending us a car
thanks to Ken yeah you don't came you
still warm
oh good yeah good that's great sure you
don't warm we're all good all right
let's go I'm not scared